[Musique]
nous sommes en Virginie en plein cœur
des montagnes Appalaches où l'économie
régionale repose encore sur les
gisements de charbon ceci depuis
l'arrivée des chemins de fer au 19e
siècle
[Musique]
les montagnes ont été déc
apites sol sa
ccagés soumis
[Musique]
une fois utilisé elles sont abandonnées
exemples aujourd'hui impossible d'y
faire pousser quoi que ce soit à part
peut-être du foie
en Virginie à deux heures de noxwiller
que se trouve une des anciennes mines de
charbon
jusqu'à ce qu'il y en ait plus
pendant 15 ans c'était un champ
abandonné dit-il et on s'est dit que ce
serait un bon endroit pour y installer
des panneaux solaires les parcs varient
entre 30 et 121 hectares et vont générer
chacun entre 10 et 40 mégawatts
d'électricité qui vont au total
alimenter 15000 foyers en Virginie
fait partie des six sites qui vont être
convertis
plaque dit-elle on peut travailler
dessus Betty Allen est une des
directrices à centrale organismes
spécialisés sur les panneaux solaires
c'est une portion de 30 hectares ici les
panneaux vont générer 10 mégawatts
d'électricité qui pourront alimenter
1500 maisons
[Musique]
on espère que ces panneaux vont aussi
générer des emplois dans les communautés
qui ont longtemps répondu vitamines les
sites des mines des affectées font
partie des cent mille hectares de
terrains dans les Appalaches acquis par
l'organisme américain nature
des endroits les plus importants sur
terre dit-il il faut préserver la
biodiversité
d'autoroute pour la faune et la flore
les Appalaches par le même d'un corridor
essentiel que les espèces vont utiliser
pour se déplacer vers le nord à cause du
réchauffement climatique
quand on parle d'espèces on ne parle pas
seulement de la faune mais des plantes
et des arbres
se déplacent déjà dit-il 10 km par
décennie c'est très rapide
n'ont pas la même biodiversité que
l'Amazonie dit-il mais il revêtent la
même importance
la plus grande forêt tempérée qui reste
dans le monde avec un important
réservoir de carbone
iards d'îles la nature s'éteint si elle
n'a pas d'endroit pour grandir pour
s'épanouir
il y a encore de l'espoir dites avec un
brin d'optimisme on travaille fort pour
trouver des solutions tous les jours
dit-il
le monde est en train de réaliser de
plus en plus qu'il faut faire face à
cette menace ensemble Virginie
[Musique]